i love guys to smoke crack
what is that a more refiner
in what ways
they pay more
they [ __ ] less
because they can't they can't get that
i've heard that
so they don't pay you to stay
they just want somebody to smoke with
yeah
there's all kinds out there aren't there
yeah
the majority of your customers are white
or black mexican
masculine mexican
you work uh figueroa
mostly
flavor war western western
butterfly when did you start doing this
when i was 15 15.
how did your parents let you do this
um my mom didn't know i was running away
from placement
oh is that right yeah what was going on
what's going on at home that you
um my mom
was on drugs and we got taken away
so where's your dad
well what my mom gave gave us to the
system but where was your dad
my dad was in jail
[Music]
so when you're in the foster system you
snuck out and
well i was running away to my friend's
house and i ended up running to pimps on
my way like to the train station or
just walking into the bus and i grew up
all over ago so meeting a pimp at 15 is
the beginning of it all
yeah yeah
you remember your first trick
um my first trick i didn't even have to
[ __ ] him
perfect
he gave me five hundred dollars but he
was a older guy i used to meet him
buy the donut shop and he used to give
me 20 every day
and one day he told me to come meet him
buy his house he wanted to show me his
house
so i was like okay
but when i got out of school i walked a
whole another way around
and i never went back i just told him
about uh like i had a fire in my house
and my clothes got burned i needed new
stuff so he gave me five hundred dollars
and i didn't know was it true or you
were hustling
i was hustling yeah
i didn't know but i knew this grown man
wasn't supposed to talk to me you know
and i've been around
like
the game
i didn't know fully but i knew he was
out of line so i know i can distort him
how much how much of this is hustling
uh
it's all hustling but but how much of it
is just like outright
not necessarily and you have a good
mouthpiece
i'm sorry if you have a good mouthpiece
you can you know really
get more money of a guy yeah
sometimes i speak spanish and sometimes
i speak english and then i'll act like i
don't even know what spirit is they're
talking about to get my money i'm like
no i didn't say that what are you
talking about
what's your favorite kind of trick
messiness
mexicans
they come quick and they give you the
money they don't give you no problem
it ain't about like
just
the sex it's it's the money like he
don't come
i'm gonna give my money
faster you come the faster i get my
money and pass out it goes to somebody
else how much money are you typically
making tonight
like nine 900 yeah but you're living in
motels
i have a story to tell
it's fascinating how these girls can
make so much money but then they're
they're living day by day
that's
like i can say right now i'm being a
half a whole
because i'm not really doing it
but i'm doing it
whatever i was doing it
ah
i have tell me your story i'm trying to
get out the game
everybody's trying to get out
i want to get out
but if i tell this then that's going to
make me have to get out oh i see
maybe this will maybe this will be the
impetus to get out
okay
i have
i'm look like
my mom have nine kids i'm the oldest
i have seven brothers i have one sister
and my mom she you know she tried hard
to raise us but it was hard when you
know the drugs came out in the 80s it
was very hard
and she tried so she couldn't
she couldn't get us
you know fetus properly she can't do the
things you know
to feed nine kids to house nine kids
at that time and it was making it hard
for her
so she gave us to the system she told
them to come get us i was watching my
brothers and sisters every day
cooking and cleaning when i was 10 years
old nine years old and i missed that you
know
and when i went in
i'm thinking that they was gonna treat
me better
they treated me so messed up
my first
placement i went to it was the 91st
earthquake
and the lady had glass all over her
windows
all over her
room it was like like shiny little
things
and earthquake came and my momma bought
me a me sized dog that was the only
thing she had bought me and i had that
of hers
and
when the earthquake happened i'm just
standing in my bed and the bed is
shaking i'm not knowing what's going on
i'm just in there by myself you know
they never came in here and looked for
me nothing
the next morning she woke up and she
said who did this you did this
and she started beating me with a doll
the dog that my mama bought me
said i broke her trying to all her stuff
in the room
so after that that made me scared of
earthquakes she slept through the
earthquake
yeah she slept and she didn't come check
on me or nothing
so
when i went back to court
they were supposed to
not take me back to that placement but
when the court was over they was putting
me back on the bus and
put me back in that placement and i was
like no i don't want to go back
the lady's beating me and then it was
like you have to go back and i refuse to
get on the bus and that's the only
reason why they didn't take me back and
i went to other placements and
things happened
sexually
um ended up
going back to my mama but
you were how old about this time like
12.
and
i got pregnant
at
twelve
no thirteen i got picking at thirteen
and i end up having
who's the caller
um this young boy that stayed with my
brothers and grandmother because my
brothers stayed with their grandmother
when it was
in foster care and i stayed out i stayed
with my grandma but then i moved into a
foster care because my grandma moved to
texas or mississippi somewhere and i
don't want to go because i want to stay
close to my mother
so
i end up
going over my grandmother house my
brothers and grandma our house i met him
and i ended up
getting pregnant
do you have the child
i have three now
do you raise your kids um
i got all taken away
due to my mento
what's what's going on mentally that you
lost your kids um
yeah just being a foster kid i was in
the orphanage like uh
mclaren hall
you only post a stage there for 15 days
i stayed there for a whole year
and they got shut down rise i left
and i was telling them what was
happening in there and what was going on
and
they didn't really do nothing about it
it was a lot of stuff going on
what was mclaren hall like i've heard a
lot of
people tell me about them um
you can say
it was like
fun on fridays that was it
you're just going to big field
and you're you can you can't go swimming
ain't no guard
um there's nothing on the big field you
play basketball
but if you do something wrong they
restrain you
and i heard that they're supposed to put
their hands on you like that
and i used to get restrained a lot
the strain means what
like sumo wrestling like body sound like
like wc ws
like oh oh get over here
you get physical with it yeah
there's no sexual abuse there though
yeah that's actual booze yeah it was
this is where we're putting our kids
yeah um i had a real i had a real bad
and that made me
like i feel like made me who i am today
and how i
look at authority
like they raised me you know
all my life i got a system so i was 18.
all i know is therapy doctors
over and over counseling
meds
i didn't i didn't want to take none of
that stuff when i was younger but i took
it one time
i never did counseling narrative therapy
until i got
wrong
i never took it serious i used to cuss
my therapist out
i didn't understand life you know at
that time
and i thought like everything that was
teaching me was a punishment you know
instead of me being home with my mom
everything was a punishment because
we got abused
so i just wanted to run away
i used to fight
i'm like i'm a loner
i'm a popular loner
i have to be by myself
i can't be around fake people
i'm paranoid i better get like people
rather to get me
you know
you know if you lie to me you do
anything like
it's made me paranoid i trusted people
when i trusted them with my life and now
i'm here
i'm still here doing this and
in some way i feel like
that's what they want me to do
if you know where i live right now
oh my god
i don't even want to cry like this
i feel like the system failed me
took me my mom was there
trying to get us back the whole time but
they wouldn't give her back because she
didn't have a a home to fit nine kids
but they ended up giving my brothers and
then back to my mama when she had a two
bedroom
and my brothers were sleeping on the
floor she had five boys back teenagers
she didn't know what to do she had to
take him to the doctor counseling this
and this and this this and this is
rushing back out of nowhere but y'all
took forever to put me back
and i you know i held my mom out
through all the struggles
i did what i had to do
and this that's all i know
you've been doing you've been in this
situation for how long
work in the street
15
look how old are you now
35 no
i'd be 36 next month
doing this kind of work gets you down
because everyone down
yeah
because i know i'm better
i'm worth more i feel like
[ __ ] should have a value
and they do they put a value on it you
know
they they
it seemed like they all grew up and set
a price on this
this
degrading sometime
but that's all i know
that's what i grew up on
it's like
being out here is
family that's all you know how to get
money that's what you feel safe doing
that's what you know how to do
do you have any friends
real friend no friends
i have one best friend but i've been on
for 16 years
i don't mess with females
i don't trust them
it's got to be a hard life
it is because everyone's a hustler
everyone is a hustler
are you a hustler at heart or you just
have to because you're out here
i'm a hustler at heart because
on the weekend
i'll be
in a drug house
on the weekdays
i'm sad
i'm with the white folks
and i learned
the inside
and i learned the outside
just by
being
brought around that stuff
i got a show i didn't know what crack
was
until they started showing me on tv
but
i had a bad social worker
she used to cuss me out show me
i ain't gonna be [ __ ]
[Music]
my mama crackhead i'm never going back
home with her
and she's a social worker would tell you
this at what age
at i was 14 i was that's when i got i
got pregnant again
but they never told me that they had
places for kids that's pregnant
they end up telling me afterwards and i
end up going to a place
where they had all pregnant girls there
and
people with children i'm like the only
girl
up there
that's not pregnant and just had an
abortion
and now y'all got me around all these
kids
i'm babysitting kids though i'm a good
mother
i was babysitting everybody kids for a
dollar
per hour
[Music]
and i i used to make fake baby concert
uh fake
baby contracts tell them i say hey i
watch a baby for this many hours i used
to get 60 a week
so i said i'm a hustler at heart
but
learning the inside of the game and the
outside of it the manipulation and the
reverse psychology
i learned it for the white folks when i
was in placement
they used it on me
i had doctors i'm not saying like white
folks that's what mostly my
doctors and psychology you know
therapist and
counselor was
and
i had black people
but it was real me
it was meaner
you still talk to your family
yeah
i talked to him mostly
so i started yesterday
did you ever when you were younger have
dreams of doing something with your life
you said what did you have dreams of
doing something
with your life
you're a kid
i want to be a rapper
i'm not the best rapper but
i got something to say i'm like dre
but i want to do clothing
i
like to crochet blankets
purses
i like to do arts and crafts
and i learned that in placement
i learned to crochet from this mexican
lady
she didn't speak no english and she
should go every time i mess up she go no
and point and then do it and i learn
just like that i can make you a whole
blanket
is it is it scary for you to think about
getting out because this is all you've
ever done
it's time i can't
i can't keep doing this i'm hurting you
know a lot of people
most of all you know i'm hurting myself
because i know things i want to do but
dealing with my mental
it's like i fight with a lot of stuff
you know
what emotions do you deal with mostly
you're depressed
like i used to hear voices
and they used to talk about my mom and
talk about my daughter and i'm thinking
like man i never thought this would be
me
you know am i tripping
so i've been you know taking medicine
[Music]
you know i think about my past and
my future like
i like to be alone a bear came i'm like
a bear
in hibernation i gather up all my food
when i hide in the house
but it's like anybody i run into know
what i do either
already doing it or want me to do it for
him
i never can run into a prince charming
guy
you think you you've never run into one
yeah like pretty woman yeah
a lot of the girls dream about
some guy coming and saving them
that was a good
movie
that that really like explains it
you have a pimp currently
yeah
how's it treat you
hold it off okay
but knowing that i want to stop is like
putting a fight towards what
how we you know we talk to each other
and stuff this
the money i made
i say i'm a vet
i gotta get up out of this you know i
got
ain't no 4-1 okay ain't no
retirement checking this you know i
can't keep living like this off my body
i'm like worn myself out i'm getting all
these bruises all over me and
it's getting more dangerous out there
girls are getting killed
yeah
and i don't want to you know end up on
the news
you know somewhere
well we don't really end up on the news
that much i heard you know a lot of
stuff
if you were to somehow get away
yeah i may do some stuff would there be
any money
in your pocket or no
um
i had
i really didn't have no money when a guy
was trying to rob me i was trying to go
get some weed for my weed man
and i got in the car with him he was
like he wanted a date and i'm like
he was like i'm not black i'm like why
would you say that
and most guys say that they you know
they're trying to do something but you
know like trying to say i'm not black
and
so to tell like they're a cool guy
and i get in this car
i get his back seat
and he was like give me a [ __ ] money
[ __ ] he
turned me to the side and i couldn't get
up
but then he dug in my pocket and he said
i would rob you give me your [ __ ]
money
and then you dug in my pocket to get my
money out i'm like okay you had that
i can't move i'm stuck
and then when he tried to he said now
i'm gonna take your [ __ ] i said oh no
you gotta be [ __ ] up
you can't you can't you can't take my
[ __ ] i i can't let that happen that's
that's right
so i'd rather fight for my life so when
i started fighting that's when he like
started jumping in the front seat and
like when i was trying to get out i just
stalked him in the back of his head and
he rolled off
you were able to get out
yeah
he took my little 30 that i have for my
weed
that's it
but it could have been worse because i
couldn't move
things like this happened to you before
yeah when i first started
this guy
choked me
but i'm a big girl so
i choked him back
he saw how strong i was he said get out
and then he started choking me again and
i started choking him
so
i got away though
but this one guy had a gun
and i knew i had to like give it up it
was like
what else can you do
that's when you have to give it up
but it's still right
anything i do for free is right
they don't feel that though
i had something recent happen to me the
guy
acted like he wanted me to try to pull
over to the side and
i told him i said you messing with the
wrong prostitute and i kicked him
and his stomach had his feet his whole
body up to the window
and i pepper sprayed him
and i left my phone inside his car and
then when i bend down to get it he
stalked him in my face but i was like
okay i'm about to fight this man when he
about to go away he already pepper
sprayed so
have you ever seen
any
anyone in your life any examples of a
loving relationship
like your mom or uncles or aunts or
anything like that
um
the most i saw was
my grandmother and her husband but they
stayed in seven rooms
he was hispanic his name was robert
and he was a good guy though but
he to bring the money home
give me a hundred dollars every
week
i'll put it up
my grandma used to cook for him
i bring his food i'll be at his dinner
where he's sleeping
and i used to watch tv all day
until he get home
i used to steal his quarters
he used to be right there he's the
counter but it'll be so many
i used to steal him and go to the donut
truck
what's your favorite memory in your life
is that what what's your favorite memory
of your life
my favorite memory
um
just being at home
with my brothers and sisters and cooking
and cleaning and
like just being a mom towards them
i wish i had that like the whole time
growing up like being with my family
going to the foster system is probably
the worst thing that ever happened to
you guys right yeah that's the worst
thing that ever happened like
now i can't waste that about nobody
and
when
i got older
i when i got my kids sick away
i thought that i was ready to fight
against them
but i
wasn't
they gave me the same courtroom that i
had that i was a child
as an adult
so the judge knew me
as
a child and as an adult
so i felt they used you know my history
of my when i was a child i used to fight
a lot
girls
guys
whatever
because they used to pick on me
but i'll be the one here first and i get
in trouble because i beat them up
and
that was all of my in my history and
then i used to put staff on ya
i've been to central
sylmore
camp scott
kirby
anazuka
almost went to y.a
what kind of things were you doing that
got you
um
my social worker the one that i had that
i said that used to cuss me out
um she said that i threw the phone at
her
so she felt threatened for her life so i
went um
to jail the first time for that
and then the second time
i went
this uh
lady said that i threatened the whole
group home
and said that i was going to
beat up everybody in the group home
which i didn't say that
did you would you
say that you carry a lot of care around
a lot of anger
yeah
who do you think you're angry at
my judge
just everybody in the courtroom they all
know me
it's like
fighting towards them to try to get my
kids back you know it was hard
knowing that y'all raised me y'all saw
me all the time
and of course
i used to go to court every 15 days
they used to tell me no you ain't not
going home
they told me that she only posted me
there 15 days and they supposed to find
you a place i stayed there for a whole
year
and a lot of stuff went on and i don't
want to talk about you know i got a
court case
stuff going on
i don't know if that's in it
i don't want to talk about it but it's
other stuff it's deeper y'all hear about
it
if y'all see me on here
but
i'm just it made me a fear of authority
it's hard to trust anybody when
everyone's
yeah i can't even go
inside a building to take care of my
my my personal business i get anxiety
these are my talking i think they're
making fun of me
i think
that they trying to mess up my paperwork
on purpose
like
i feel like
they just after me the [ __ ] of my life
they want me to be [ __ ] up like i felt
like all the foster kids told me [ __ ]
that
there's always something wrong with us
what is it
you know
my brothers and if they grew up with
their grandma but then they ended up
getting foster care afterwards and they
saw you know what we went through
and the social worker we had
she's the customer i'm out she's because
my sister out
she's because
my mother grandma grandmother out
and i'm like
this lady supposed to represent me in
court
and we used to talk about each other i
used to call her all kind of [ __ ] she
caught me all the kind of [ __ ] who
could talk each other ugly [ __ ]
whatever and then when somebody reported
coming we all like this
yes
how are you today lacora
oh that's my name oh my god
she's all faking stuff and i used to
tell them all that stuff about what she
used to do
they didn't care
and then when i got my kids ticket my
baby dad
he was supposed to be on my side
he made it harder for me
and
he made me like knowing that he knew my
temper
and how i felt towards the courts
i you can't make somebody do something
but he knew that he could make my blood
bubble
and i said
go off on him in court and
it made me look bad
and then me crying like i'm a crybaby
now and i cry i lied for everything
but i don't
i don't cry
it's hard for me to cry
and crying right now is
like yeah i say in the real me
but
having the people that i thought i was
gonna have my back and fight against him
and i wasn't ready
it took a lot out of me and then
just having the same courtroom as a
child
seeing the same judge that i knew
my [ __ ] my foul was like this big she
can't even see me
and i felt like they didn't give me a
chance for my other hands and i felt
they set me up
to get my other kids together
do you feel like it's such it's never
got me
had my back always i always been
homeless it's almost like your whole
life the cars have been stacked against
you yeah
i've been homeless since i left the
system i just now got my own place
and
it's been hard just keeping that and
maintaining that and
because i'll be out here
and i'm scared i'm a loser i don't want
to
lose what i have because
you know
i got family
i got kids
that want to come
you know a visit
i don't even see my son though
he's adopted fully
[Music]
he got adopted first
when he was three
and that's messed up because were you in
the system
when your mother
has you in the system
and then your kids go in the system
if you was in the system you can't get
your grandkids
so
i didn't have a chance for my mother to
step in and grab my my kids for me
and then when the dad was coming in to
grab my son
he got killed
and
so they was like your time is that
he's to get adopted
i did my classes i did everything they
wanted me to do
i graduated from them i graduated from
high school
but i graduated when i was in dirt to
kirby in the mental institution
but that's the one thing i wanted to do
was finish school
and i told them they used to like want
to restrain me
because i was acting up because i was
about to get into a fight and they said
you can't go to school and i'm like you
can't deprive me of my education my
education is so that
like let me go to school
but
i'm glad i'm glad i did that i used to
work
i had jobs you paid jobs yeah
you're telling me you have mental issues
but you seem pretty
together you're just going through a lot
of tough breaks
no i have my ups and downs
i have my snaps
i have i'm like i'm highly medicated
yeah i take a bit of fire a shot
every month
and i take some other pills
so it keeps me like mellow
sleepy
qui slow to react on things
controls your anger
it really does
like i said when i was younger i refused
to take them on and took them like one
time
but as an adult
i thought it wasn't going to work
but ever since i've been taking the bill
of fire
it's really been keeping me like
calm but i still react on a lot of
things when i'm angry i like i go to the
stream because i think like it's the end
of the world
[Music]
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
you
as a blessing as a lesson you're gonna
learn something
ain't gonna be blessed with something
and
you gotta take everything as a blessing
and a lesson
and
just live your life
do what you say you gonna do
no one has to say
have patience
but
in my mind
i got to do everything
and i did not
everything cluttered
yep you have nobody to
rely on right
um
i have a caretaker that helps a little
bit but
um
just like
most of the days like
i just like i don't look pretty like
this it's not i can just look like an
ancient mama you won't even know who i
am you're beautiful today
today because i tried to do this hair i
tried i tried it i tried out the youtube
i'm very like
artistic i couldn't do anything i didn't
do my own hair i did my own lace front
and it's a new style everybody got
so
but i i um i struggled through a lot of
suicidal attempts
[Music]
and
i still even though i'm on my education
i still hear my voices sometimes but
i try to block them out and be normal
like everybody else
but i feel that everybody's crazy
in different ways
yeah because when i was in the system
they said
you gotta express each each emotion
if you're happy you're sad you're angry
but the way i stress mine is where i
grew up
always breaking stuff fighting
getting restrained and as an adult i'm
still doing the same thing
when i get mad
like a kid
you ever done therapy
i'm about to get one okay
i had one
but
i kept getting therapy therapy therapy
therapy over like different
therapies therapies i mean yeah you're
just talking about your childhood
yeah over and over and i don't want to
keep starting over and over like
let's get this out
let's figure some stuff out here like
i've been through this over and over
every time you want to hear the same
story make me cry
tell me about your life no
i already told this last lady about my
life
i'm tired of starting over so it's like
they don't get that
in therapy
and they want to know
like what keep people in therapy it's
like trying to get out
their whole life
in one sitting yeah it does you can't
get it out but you want to let them know
like what you're going through so they
can try to fix
what you're going through now
like i'm gonna let you know my past
presence
and my future i want you to fix my
present
all right butterfly well thank you so
much for sharing your story
okay i wish you the best of luck out
there
thank you thanks very much all right
you